>> A major element of most traditional
approaches to image processing involves
statistical analysis and manipulation
of the pixel values in the image.
Many of the techniques we rely on to glean information from
an image rely on a good level of contrast in the image,
enabling us to identify features clearly.
Suppose we've taken a photograph in challenging light conditions.
So it's underexposed and rather dark and gloomy.
Or maybe the images overexposed and washed out.
Either way, the level of contrast in the image
makes it hard to pick out detailed visual features.
Ideally, we would want to adjust
these images to have
a more uniform contrast that makes them easier to work with.
Well, let's explore what this actually means when
we're talking about an array of pixel values.
Now we know that our image consists of
pixel values in the range of 0-255,
and if we were to plot a histogram of those values showing how
frequently each possible pixel value appears in the image,
it might look something like this.
If we calculate the cumulative distribution function
or CDF of the histogram,
we can view the pixel values cumulatively.
In other words, from left to right,
we can see how the pixel intensities from
0-255 are added to the image.
A simple way to approach improving
the contrast is simply to stretch the histogram,
scaling the values from the lowest to the highest,
in the hope that this will spread more evenly.
The histogram itself remains the same shape,
as the relative distribution of the values doesn't change,
but the contrast in the image may improve,
and you might see some of the bumps in
the CDF gets smoothed out a little.
That technique is called contrast
stretching or sometimes histogram stretching.
Now more sophisticated approach is to
normalize the pixel values on a scale of
0-255 based on adjusting
the image so that the most frequent intensities
are spread out evenly.
This has the effect of flattening the histogram,
which in turn produces a CDF that shows
a clear diagonal accumulation due to
a relatively uniform frequency of pixel intensities.
Then don't worry. There are multiple libraries
in Python that will do the math for you.
The important thing is that the end result of all of
this is an image with improved contrast.